this could quite possibly be the coolest
piece of tech I've ever had the chance
to review let's go to the Moon
thank you to Olsen for partnering with
me on this video this is the osim you
love 3 well-being chair with four hand
massage technology and designed in
collaboration with panin Farina the
Italian design house the design Ferrari
and more I have never owned a massage
chair before but you better believe that
anytime I see one of these at someone
else's house at the mall or the airport
I will definitely be taking full
advantage of it but for some reason I
never really thought about ever getting
one for my home but today my friends we
are living the dream
foreign so this chair is made by the
company osim who well I'm not gonna lie
I've actually never heard of them before
and that's mostly because they are
heavily featured in Asia actually they
are the leading brand of Premium massage
chairs in Asia and they're a Pioneer in
the wellness tech industry they've been
around since 1980 and have been at the
Forefront of research development and
Innovation the chair that we're checking
out today is the new osim you love 3 and
this comes in three different colors a
red a black and brown they also have a
huge line of other well-being chairs
smart sofas gaming chairs and more what
if that was really interesting is this
company strives to create an ecosystem
of products to provide a holistic
digitized well-being experience I know
sometimes digital and health and
well-being doesn't necessarily all go
together but all of this is backed by
approved clinical research medical
certifications and scientific studies
and of course what I love so much about
this chair is how super techy it is it
has an AI stress analysis that will
measure your body tension score it
creates a personalized body tension
program they based on that score and you
can create specialized massage programs
for yourself and everyone in your family
it's pretty cool how this has the
ability to monitor your stress and
figure out a program that will let you
achieve total relaxation so to get
started there's an NFC touch point right
here on the arm of this phone holder and
this will let you download the app or
open it for quick control you can stream
music get access to all of their curated
massage programs make customizations and
adjust your chair's position what's
really cool is the more you use the
chair you'll get to see your Trends
change in your body tension score your
heart rate and your respiratory rate
over time I am such a huge fan of
tracking my data about my body whether
it's my heart rate my respiratory rate
my blood oxygen level basically any
piece of data that I can collect I am so
here for it so I'm pretty excited that
this kind of now integrates into my
health ecosystem so inside of the app
this is where you can check out the full
Suite of massage programs that can cater
to whatever your needs are it has auto
program programs designed with different
Lifestyles and targeted body relief
there's new programs that are added
regularly so you'll be able to down them
whenever you want now what makes this
different than most regular massage
chairs is this has signature and
patented massage Technologies V hand
plus mimics the hands of a professional
masseuse that gives you an ultra
realistic massage with kneading and
gripping motions it has an enhanced 720
degree ruler design that follows the
Contours of your body in a fluid motion
with four sets of massage rollers trying
this out for the first time was pretty
shocking because I've never really felt
this type of massage experience before
so it was really cool to just kind of
chill relax and just be as an avid
Runner my legs are often feeling so
tight so this has been really awesome
for leg massages it's designed for wide
and narrow calves so it'll give you a
full massage all the way to your ankles
and feet now here's an example of what a
massage program might look like
depending on your body tension score
you'll see if it's low it'll play
uplifting cheerful music and give you a
balanced massage now if you're super
stressed and in the high range it'll
give you some mellow and calming music
and a massage design for maximum stress
relief so this is controlled by an app
so I'm gonna get this all connected and
the cool thing about this is everything
that you would need to do is right here
and your phone and the fact that they
even have this nice little phone holder
for you I mean it's incredible like
everything is so perfectly thought out
there's also a little USB port right
here so you can charge your phone your
iPad this will also extend large enough
to be able to hold an iPad this has some
biometric sensors here on the hand rest
which will take your heart rate and
it'll even track your breathing so it's
able to give you an assessment based on
your current stress levels let's start
our AI stress analysis where to place
our hands on the biometric sensor here
and we're gonna wait five seconds and
breathe normally
foreign
we've got a 34 heart rate 58 and now
we're going to start a recommended
massage program now this is cool because
it's going to take my stress levels and
get me a recommended massage so now
we're going to press and hold to adjust
the chair
and
here we go
it's happening
another thing that I like that this has
is it actually has a warming mechanism
so I'm gonna press that as well I'm
gonna turn that on I don't know if
that's recommended for this massage but
it feels so nice it makes the chair all
warm it's so great
drag to adjust the shoulder position so
this has Auto shoulder detection
can you believe that it's so great like
how do you know about my shoulders oh
yeah the calf massage so nice another
thing that this does is it has speakers
and because this is connected to
Bluetooth I'm able to play that music
which I have turned down for copywritten
reasons but it'll come over these
loudspeakers and this morning I was uh I
was scrolling through Tick Tock so
basically anything that is playing in my
phone will also come over these speakers
and it sounds so good like this is I
just don't ever want to leave my feet
are vibrating
oh it's so great as a safety precaution
they do alternate between the left and
the right when they're massaging your
hands so if you do have an emergency and
you need to get out like your hands are
available I don't really want to keep
filming this video I just want to sit
here it feels so great I'm pretty
excited because they did send me this
red one to review but I have a black one
that I'm going to be keeping in my home
I'm actually really surprised how
awesome this red looks like it is just
so vibrant that it really does feel like
I'm in some sort of like Ferrari
spaceship like this feels like I'm about
ready to take off to the moon no joke so
nice it's so great I've honestly never
felt a massage chair that was this good
and I've sat in a lot of them all around
the world in malls in airports in other
people's homes in convention centers
hotels so inside of the app you do have
access to all sorts of other things so
there's a manual massage program so
you're able to select the parts of your
body that you want to get massaged these
are downloadable programs that you're
able to download There's a detox immune
booster healthy mum there's a gentle
massage for seniors so it's really nice
to know that they have all of these
downloads that are updated pretty
frequently so you'll be able to just add
different massage programs into the
chair at any time when they update them
and in here this will give you the
position of your chair so if you want to
go into zero gravity which
please hold I'm gonna do right now
I'm just so freaking comfortable like I
don't want to get out of this chair ever
do you hear that music playing right now
that is coming through the speakers I
just kind of wanted to give you an
example of what that sounds like to me
it sounds absolutely crystal clear
because it's right here by my ears so
it's nice because you don't actually
have to wear any headphones the music
just is there there are controls here on
the armrests that will let you control
various things the foot rest the back
rest but the app is so easy and
intuitive that it makes it so easy to
just go and connect it to Bluetooth and
then you have full control over the
entire device I will be putting a link
in the description if you want to check
out oh Sims You love three chair and a
whole of the other incredible products
that they have this is by far the most
relaxing and fun review that I have ever
done and I am so so hyped about this so
thank you guys for watching if you
haven't already subscribed please do so
and hit the Bell to be notified when I
post new videos and let me know what
your stress relief routine looks like
have you added a massage into that
because this for sure is definitely now
part of this is a part of my life this
is who I am oh I'll see you later bye
[Music]